[Music]
all right hey everybody told you I was
going to come back on Sunday and do a
movie review even though got to admit
I'm still not feeling like a 100% I do
feel a lot better than I did like the
last one I did and I feel a lot better
than I did Friday night last time we
streamed but I still feel a little bit
weird so uh you know please forgive me
I'm sure it's going away I hope so
anyway uh also forgive I don't you can
probably can't hear it now but there's
just all kind of like sirens and [__]
like screaming outside I have no idea
what the hell is going on out there but
um it's really loud so they only just I
had to wait cuz they were like taking
forever to pass and I'm just like oh my
god what the hell is going on out there
it must be like a big accident or fire
or something I don't know what it is but
it's crazy so yeah so we are going to
talk about another horror movie today
this one was another
recommendation um Trey says am I the
only Watcher probably I only just came
on so and I never I never warn people
ahead of time like sometimes I'll say
like I said Friday night I said oh you
know I watched a movie so I'll probably
do a review of it on Sunday but I don't
ever have any like idea when I'm going
to be able to do it you know what I mean
so I'm just kind of like I'll just pop
on whenever I can pop on so hey hey Trey
hey Tammy uh hey what's going on uh so
yeah so this movie
today I kind of I feel like one of you
guys recommended it in the chat although
I can't remember
I maybe it was on one of our other movie
reviews or something like that and this
movie is from
2018 and it's called await further
instructions now unlike uh the movie
that was recommended before that I had
never even heard of before which was the
limouse Golem this movie I had actually
heard of it and it actually was on my to
watch list because I don't know if it's
on shutter anymore but it was like for a
long time so I kept seeing it like time
I was scrolling through shutter and I'm
like man that kind of looks good I
should probably watch that like it
sounded good from the synopsis but for
whatever reason I had just hadn't gotten
around to it so when somebody
recommended it um I was like okay well I
might as well I don't like I said I
don't think it's on shutter anymore but
it is on a bunch of other free streaming
platforms like I watched it on tub I
think it's also on Pluto it might be on
Redbox so it's on in a bunch of places
where you can watch it for free um and I
think whoever recommended it also said
that I should to do a double feature
with the signal and that's what that was
what I was going to do I've seen the
signal before but it was so long ago
that I you know would need to watch it
again like to review it but the signal
didn't seem to be available for free
anywhere and I kind of wanted to get
something up so I was like you know what
I'll just do that one later on this
one's free I'm going to watch it and I
haven't seen this one and I've been
wanting to see it so that's how that
worked out so like I said this movie
came out in 2018 and it's British and
the interesting thing about this is that
I decided to it not knowing that this is
actually a Christmas horror movie so I'm
like oh well that worked out really good
I didn't realize that it was cuz they
don't you know if you look at um you
know the title card and stuff like that
it doesn't really look like a Christmas
hor there's not Christmas lights or any
of that kind of [__] on there but uh it
absolutely does take place at Christmas
so I was like oh well that's good that
I'm reviewing it in December
then so as I mentioned this is a British
film now it starts out
as kind of I guess what you call like a
psychological horror or like
psychological drama type thing and then
towards the end it goes kind of in
a cronenbergian
Direction I want to say it's kind of
SciFi um so so just know that going in
like it kind of looks sci-fi from it's
not like hard sci-fi or anything but it
is kind of sci-fi-ish cronenbergian body
horrorishalloween toward the end you
know what I mean okay so it goes that
way like I don't want to spoil it
because it's not that old but just know
it's not going to be like a whole drama
the whole way in and it does have like
Supernatural sort ofish uh you know so
it's not like Killers or anything like
that so this was written by Gavin
Williams and directed by Johnny
kavorkian who I don't know what else he
did I thought I read somewhere that he
had passed away but I'm not entirely
sure about that this seems to be like
his best known movie
so this movie um seems like it was
fairly lowbudget that's not a ding
against it I'm just saying you know it's
obviously like an indie movie but pretty
high concept uh for all that and I feel
like if you're into something like Black
Mirror this is kind of like a Black
Mirror type situation um or if you liked
real um like ambitious one location High
concept sci-fi-ish kind of movies like
something like coherence uh which I
think I've talked about before which is
great if you haven't seen that um which
took place pretty much all in one house
but was like I like I said really high
concept this is kind of a similar Vibe
it's not exactly the same but it's kind
of in the same ballpark you know what I
mean so if you liked coherence if you
like black mirror if you like stuff like
that then you would probably dig this so
here's the
setup um you have your main character I
guess who's kind of like this kind of
20-some guy guy named Nick and he's
bringing his newish girlfriend uh Angie
back to his family home for
Christmas now it's pretty obvious from
the way he's like reacting to everything
that Nick uh was not a fan of this idea
like coming back to see his family and
pretty much only went along with it
because Angie pretty much insisted that
she wanted to meet his relatives like I
you know it's kind of implied I guess
that they've been going out for a while
maybe a year or two or whatever and um
you know she's like oh I want to meet
your family I want to see where you come
from and stuff and he's just like really
do we have to and he's like okay fine
you know um and we find out later
actually that Nick has not spoken to his
family at all for 3 years and after we
meet them um it becomes pretty apparent
why that is and you can't really like
[__] blame the dude either you what
I'm going to
say so Nick's mom Beth who answers the
door um she mostly seems okay she's a
little bit mousy little bit of a doormat
submissive type but his dad
Tony is a real piece of work um he's
kind of one of those super he's very
very conservative very religious um very
rigid very arrogant um kind of one of
those MyWay or the highway type people
who's like always right and thinks
everybody else is a weak ass pansy like
one of those kind of people uh you know
and he kind of makes a lot of comments
to that effect like toward his son like
that he thinks he's weak or
whatever and then when we meet Gramps
Grandpa Granddad whatever you want to
call him I think they usually call him
Gramps um we can see where the dad got
it from you know what I mean cuz yeah
great he's just a chip off the old block
cuz Gramps is even even worse if that's
possible he's just like this nasty old
codger uh sitting in his chair in front
of the TV like grumbling and everything
like old man yelling a cloud you know
what I mean um and he's also gets on his
son's case who's Tony the dad about
being oh you're only an office manager I
was in the military police and I'm a
badass and all this other stuff and
you're only an office manager and he
calls him what's his nickname for him
squelcher and you find out why that is
later on
um you know so it's it's real
denigrating you know obviously so
there's that um and he goes into uh he
gets real racist as well you know like
like Grandpa does and um you know
Britain used to be great before all
these dirty foreigners came in and blahy
blah so it's basically this is like the
British Christmas equivalent of like
Thanksgiving dinner with that one Fox
News watching uncle that nobody wants to
hang with it's kind of that type of
situation
um but kind of like ex well I was going
to say it's kind of it's exaggerated but
not really cuz my grandpa's kind of like
that too so it's like it's not really
outside of the Realms of possibility
that's what I'm
saying um hey unforeseen what's up uh
this film did a great job of showing
what it's like to have a difficult
family relationship oh yeah big time and
like I said I think some reviews I read
of it said that they thought that some
of the characters were exaggerated I did
not think so um because I've own people
like that so it didn't seem exaggerated
to me at all like some of the crazy [__]
they said wasn't crazy it was just cuz
I've heard people say that say
especially like Grandpa cuz I was like
kind of sounds like my grandpa my
grandpa said worse [__] than that so you
know what I mean it was that kind of
[__] so you already have this situation
going on and you can tell like from the
get go it's like super super awkward so
you have all of these awkward moments
Gramps can't really seem to help himself
like sharing his bigoted opinions about
everything and particularly in front of
Angie who he seems to think is Middle
Eastern even though she's clearly Indian
but and she's British too I mean so I
assume her parents were Indian or
whatever but it's just like you know
she's British so uh so that's kind of
all going on and then Nick also has this
sister named Kate who is super super
pregnant and she shows up with her kind
of musclebound Chunk head of a husband
his name is Scott and the these two are
also pretty shitty um in a vaguely lower
key way um but they're both also like
complete idiots like one of the one of
the scenes that made me laugh the most
was They're all playing I think they're
I guess they're all playing Scrabble or
whatever and Angie uh you know the
Indian girlfriend she put down the word
tumult and the Sister Kate she's like
that's not a real word you know what I
mean and she's like yeah it is a real
word do you want me to get the
dictionary again again she's like yeah
but you have to use English words that's
an Indian word you know what I mean so
it's just like so these two are like
real morons you know what I mean so it's
that kind of thing um but yeah that that
really made me laugh cuz I have played
Scrabble with people that thought you
were making words up because their
vocabulary wasn't very large so I kind
of so I kind of thought that was funny
too so uh so yeah so the first part of
the movie really kind of like I want to
say the
first I don't I don't know if it's the
first half of the movie but the first
third the first half of the movie is
just kind of this horribly
uncomfortable family gathering um just
kind of getting more and more
cringeworthy and after kind of they they
aren't even there that long but Nick and
Angie realized look we don't want to
take any more of this this is like you
know it's the [__] holiday we don't
need this [__] um so let's get the
[__] out of here you can't blame them
obviously because I Al also would have
been like yeah bye I'm I'm going home
the mom Beth though she persuades him to
stay she's like uh you know I'm so sorry
that everyone is being an [__] and
it's she's just trying to desperately
make everybody get along you know like
for the sake of the holiday like Mom's
deal so Nick and Angie are kind of
grudgingly agree they're like okay if
you insist we'll do it for you Mom but
later on like they go up to the room to
kind of put their stuff away and then
Nick tells Angie she's like well
basically tomorrow morning we're just
going to get up super super early before
everybody else gets up and we're going
to get the [__] out of here we're just
going to sneak out so we don't have to
like confront anybody which like I said
you can't really blame them so Before
Dawn it's still dark out and they kind
of get set up to do the sh just that
they pack all their stuff up and they
kind of sneak down the stairs but at
this point they run into a little bit of
a snag it seems that sometime during the
night while everyone was sleeping the
house has been completely
encased in some type of like
impenetrable black barrier like they
open the door and they can't get out and
all the windows and everything like that
and then later on like Nick goes up to
the attic and sees that it's seems to
like cover the whole house right like a
like a another layer of like something
and it's black and it kind of looks like
corrugated you know what I mean but it's
like super hard and you can't get
through it like he get tries to get
through the hammer and [__] like that
and you can't so there's no way to get
out the TV in the house house has also
uh kind of started displaying this
ominous message on it and it's just kind
of in this plain like a VHS looking font
like on this kind of greenish black PL
plain screen or whatever and it says
stay inside and await further
instructions that's all it
says so as soon as the rest of the
family members get up and see what's
going on I mean obviously the dad he
wants to take charge cuz he's one of
those [__] and he's like oh
well there has to be to be some
explanation like why can't you just bust
out the barrier like you weak ass pansy
or whatever and but obviously like he
tries to do it and you can't do it
because you can't get
out so so they're all trying to figure
out what's going on and again Tony the
dad because he knows everything uh he
insists well you know what it must be
you know I know what it is it must have
been a terrorist attack because earlier
they were watching some stuff on the
news about like some weird power outages
or something like that it's like oh it's
some kind of terrorist attack and um
we've been quarantined inside the house
like for our own safety or whatever and
he also seems unshakably certain that
whoever is sending them these messages
through the TV that says await further
instructions um must have their best
interest at heart you know it's probably
the government they're telling us this
to keep us safe and so therefore any
messages that appear um should be obeyed
without
question um Nick and Angie wisely are
not so sure about that um you know it's
like I'm not sure we're down with
following whatever that's going to say
but everybody else seems kind of um
cowed by Tony I guess and they're just
kind of like eager to follow his lead I
guess they just want they're just so
used to him taking charge that they're
just kind of like okay we'll just do
whatever you say you know what I mean
now for a little
while um nothing significant happens so
you know and the message just kind of
stays there so Tony the dad he just
demands that they all sit down we're
going to have our Christmas dinner like
normal pretend everything's normal
because there's really nothing else we
can do you know what I mean but just
before they start eating the message on
the TV
changes and then it tells them all your
food is contaminated eat nothing that's
what it says now Nick and Anie thinks th
think this is like the stupidest [__]
ever um and they don't believe it
they're like you know somebody is
[__] with us come on it's like that's
how could anybody know that possibly but
Tony is like I said he just thinks
anything that comes up on that TV we
have to follow it for our own safety or
whatever so he just immediately like
gathers up all the food it was a big
Christmas dinner a turkey and all the
and all the all the stuff and he just
gathers it all up and throws it in the
garbage because it's supposedly like
contaminated and he's like okay well so
now we can't eat anything that was out
like so the only thing they can drink I
guess is like bottled water and if they
had like any wrapped protein bars or
something like that so they have to like
just eat that because apparently all the
food in the house is contaminated too so
I'm like okay and then like Scott the
the brother-in-law or whoever and he's
just sitting there going oh you can go a
long time without food blah blah blah
but they guess like the bottled water is
okay so from that point forward um the
messages on the TV and like a in weird
incidence that happened they kind of
start getting more bizarre like the TV
tells them about this vaccine protocol
and then it drops a bag of used syringes
like down the chimney um full of God
knows what they don't know what it is um
and they're all supposed to inject
themselves with it now um obviously like
Angie who is a nurse she's like you know
these are used and we don't know what's
in there like we probably shouldn't just
do it you know what I mean um but Tony's
like no this is we have to do this blah
blah blah and he's like oh okay if
you're going to be a baby about it then
we'll soak him in alcohol at least there
are you happy now it's that kind of [__]
and Nick and Angie don't really want to
do it but they sort of get uh shanghaied
into it I guess cuz everyone else does
it and they're you know they're I I I
think they're starting to get to a point
where they're like afraid that
something's going to happen to them like
if they don't go along with the crowd or
whatever so um the TV also later tells
them that there's contamination in the
air and that they should scrub
themselves with bleach so they do that
um it later tells them that one of their
number doesn't tell them which one it is
is infected and should be isolated from
the others like should be quarantined so
because Angie is the new person and also
a quote unquote Foreigner um they're
like yeah we're just going to sh lock
her up in the in a bedroom or whatever
so you know it's it's nice um so with
each new
message um it seems more and more
evident to you watching it that somebody
see and you don't know who it is is
maybe experimenting on this family like
to see how far they'll go to follow
orders even when those orders are like
clearly ridiculous or harmful or
whatever I should note um if you're
paying attention because I don't know if
they make a huge deal out of this but
they do mention it a me mentioned a
couple times but the Family's last name
is mgram uh which should kind of clue
you in and I and I believe too that the
street that they're that they live on is
called Stanford so that would be a
reference to the Stanford Prison
Experiment um and just like mgrm would
be a reference to the mgrm experiment
the um the one where they uh you know
had people shock people you know people
in doctor's coats or whatever would tell
people to shock people and most people
would just do it because it was told
them by an authority figure so that's
kind of the direction they're going with
it like I said they don't hit too hard
with that but I did notice that that was
the Family's last name you know what I
was like oh I say what you did there
okay so I I kind of see what you're
trying to do now not surprisingly
because this family was super
dysfunctional like to start with um they
kind of start to well not even kind of
they act they absolutely start to turn
on each other as the you know
instructions on the TV like start
getting farther and farther out there
and [__] starts getting like crazier and
a lot more
violent so um and to me this was like
the best part I mean I really liked this
movie a lot it's I was just riveted like
the whole time I'm like what the [__] is
going on you know what I mean because
you're not for a long time you're not
entirely sure who it is that's [__]
with this family or why they're [__]
with this family or is it just this
family is it everywhere like what's
going on you don't know because they
can't get out you know what I mean
they're in the house all they know is
like they're closed in this house and
the TV's telling them to do [__] you
know what I mean so they don't know if
it's terrorists they don't know if it's
aliens they don't know what the [__] is
going on and you don't know either so
it's actually like kind of cool because
you're just like somebody's
experimenting with these people like to
see if they're like at each other's
throats because they were so shitty to
each other before and that's kind of
what ends up happening like just they
just go at each other's throats now as I
said I'm not going to spoil the ending
but I will tell you that it's
probably not exactly what you're
expecting and that could be good or bad
like depending on how it's like I really
liked the ending um and the resol U of
like what it was that was doing this but
you know I I saw some people were kind
of like they didn't they liked the
buildup but not so much the ending but I
really liked the ending but like I said
it's
probably it might not be what you're
imagining is like I said because it's a
little weird strange not really that
weird but it does kind of like build up
to that but you know what I mean um and
I think some people maybe were confused
by it like they didn't really get what
the meaning behind it was um I wasn't
confused by it I got the meaning but
like I didn't think it was that
complicated to figure out but I'm just
putting that out there like you know um
cuz this is a fairly High concept movie
and I think it's either going to work
for you or it's not going to work for
you um but I really did like the ending
and I thought it was it so weird and
it's so grotesque um the concept it's a
little on the nose I will say that but
that didn't bother me in this latest cuz
I just thought it was kind of a cool
idea like the way they went with it so
I'm going to say I mean for a fairly
lowbudget
movie with a really limited cast there's
only like a handful of actors and a
single location this all takes place
inside one house um this was pretty damn
impressive I have to say uh the acting's
great uh the special effects looked
great I thought the look of it was
really cool it's very dark and very teal
and then it had kind of all the
Christmas stuff like Christmas lights
and stuff kind of accentuating it and I
thought that looked really cool but yeah
I really liked the effects like
especially toward the end and you know
the premise was weird and it just like
kept you guessing the whole time um and
the movie is
also it's like a really good examination
of the kind of the pitfalls of blindly
following orders like I said that's why
they reference the mgrm experiment cuz
that's what that was testing also um you
know obedience um also kind of making a
statement
on um the sway that media holds over
people
minds
and you know to and to a lesser extent
uh the tragic [__] that ensues when you
have one domineering [__] who
has to be in control at all times and
won't listen to anyone else's ideas even
when he's clearly wrong you know what I
mean um and how that can go way off the
rails which it does in this a big time
um and I so and I think anyone who's had
to like sit through just painful family
gatherings with relatives who are just
really unpleasant and just can't keep
their mouth shut about stuff because
they can't help themselves um I think
you should like really relate hard to
this movie maybe you don't want to watch
it maybe it might be kind of triggering
I don't really know but but it might
make you feel kind of better you know
what I mean you watch it like around
Christmas time you're like well at least
my family's not as [__] up with these
people you know what I mean so so it
might you know your mileage may vary on
that I'm not really sure sure and like I
said I do kind of feel like some revie
other reviews of it I read thought that
particularly the the Tony character the
dad and Gramps were a little bit
exaggerated um I didn't find that cuz
like I said I've had relatives like that
I've known people like that that said
those very things and worse than that so
that they did not seem exaggerated to me
in the slightest so like I said maybe it
seems exaggerated but I don't think it
is so so yeah I'm going to say if you're
into like
conceptual sci-fi that's kind
of more confined like to one area it's
like I said it's not hard sci-fi or
anything like that it's kind of sci-fi
tinged let's put it that way uh and it
all takes place in one location um then
you would probably dig this and like I
said it's kind of Black Mirror it GES me
gives me like a Black Mirror type of
vibe something like that um now like I
said it used to be on shutter I'm pretty
sure it's not anymore but I think at
least as of this live stream which if
you're watching this later it's December
10th 19 or 19 what the [__] Century am I
in
20123 getting old it sucks um but yeah
I'm in last century I don't even know
what [__] Century it is anymore um
but yeah so December 10th 2023 is what I
meant to say um you can actually watch
it for free on 2B which is where I
watched it uh I think it's also on Pluto
red box and I think also the Roku
channel has it for free so it's
everywhere um you can see it and like I
said it's a Christmas movie so if you're
looking for a Christmas horror that you
maybe haven't seen before I feel like
this one doesn't get brought up in when
people are talking about Christmas
horror and uh which is probably why I
didn't know it was a Christmas horror
before I watched it but I was like
really happy to find that out because I
was like oh well I'm reviewing it in
December so how how timely um all right
but yeah so it's a cool movie check it
out uh Hey everybody hey Leslie uh it's
a cool movie like the Irish isolation uh
2005 in the UK host 2020 I've actually
reviewed
isolation um not too long ago how long
ago was that I feel like I did a video
on that just like a few months ago that
was actually really good and I didn't
know anything about that movie The only
reason I picked it I saw it on shutter
and I was like um uh Sean Harris was in
it and um what's her name from the Boba
duck uh she was in it and so I was like
oh that kind of looks pretty good like I
liked the cast I didn't really know what
it was about or anything like that and I
being really good like I think I said in
that review that it's sort of
like I want to say it's sort of like an
Eco horror but like a ' 70s Eco horror
but modernized and not cheesy you know
what I mean but I really liked it I
thought it was really good um yeah it's
always the imaginative and creative
British horror yeah I love British
horror movies they tend to be really
good uh just give us the spoilers Jenny
what's keeping them in the house a
monster or creature um
kind of it's not I don't know would I
call it a
monster it's hard to
explain can I okay it's like a
conceptual monster kind of that sounds
what is that that sounds dumb I don't
but I don't I don't really know it's not
exactly a monster but it's kind of a
monster you know what I mean yeah it's
kind of like
uh sorry Tom just showed up and said
great rack a thank you
honey he's spying on me again what is
that little Emoji is that little I can't
see that good is it a little heart with
does it have hands or is it clouds I
can't see I'm so [__] blind even with
glasses on but yeah you're pretty
hilarious Tom yeah Leslie said I like
when the cable uses them as puppets yeah
that's kind of a all right that's kind
of like a spoil okay spoiler spoiler
spoiler spoiler it ends up that if you
don't want to if you don't want to know
what happens cuz you know Danny asked so
I'm going to I'm going to tell you and
Leslie kind of said something about it
too so I'm just going to say okay I
guess people don't care you know what I
mean it ends up that what the monster is
it's basically
like it's like all the um cables and
stuff like from the TV and stuff kind of
came to life kind of so it but it's
almost like they don't say if it's
interdimensional or if it's an alien or
whatever but it's just like at one point
like Angie she's up in one of the
bedrooms and she finds an old TV set and
like she pulls the back of the TV set
off and because it's doing weird [__]
like when it's not plugged in and
there's like living kind of creatures in
there like I said it's almost it's kind
of like video Drome I think somebody
mentioned video Drome earlier but it's
basically like media but like physical
media like cables and stuff but like
come to life like it's almost kind of
like morphed into a creature of some
kind and yeah it can actually um come
out the TV and like make people into
puppets and stuff like that it looks
really cool actually I think it I
thought it was like a really good
concept but like I said the concept of
it when I said it's kind of on the nose
it's basically you know physical media
has come to life and is like taking you
over and like puppeting you so they're
kind of making a statement about media
controlling people is what it is but you
know it's not super heavy-handed about
it and like I said I thought it looked
pretty cool because even the stuff that
is surrounding the house like outside
the house you don't really know what it
is at first like I said it kind of just
looks like black like corrugated metal
or something but then later on as you
realize like all these cables kind of
come out like snaky and everything like
that and kind of twist themselves
together like into configurations um you
you can see that everything like
surrounding the house is just cables
like really really close together like
like making a barrier you know what I
mean it's like that it's like
that oh it's a happy heart yeah he's
amazed
[Laughter]
a oh Tom said I may go to the garage and
install that bike battery we'll make
noise okay well I was almost done anyway
so it's so you can do that in a few
minutes it's okay he's going to get out
of the garage and make noise so he's
warning me cuz yeah I mean you guys know
like my office is right above the garage
so if anybody opens the garage door if
anybody like starts up the bike or
anything like that it's going to be
really noisy in here it's going to be
really noisy um but yeah and unforeseen
said shame that the director passed away
yeah I thought he had um I'd have to
like check again but I thought I read a
review that said that he had passed away
and I think this is kind of the main
movie that he made you know what I mean
but yeah so I guess uh Tom's going to go
work on his motorcycle so I better wrap
this up because otherwise it's going to
be really loud and I'm not going to be
able to hear myself so uh so yeah so
thanks everybody for dropping by talking
about this Christmas horror movie like I
said seems like some of you have seen it
so that's like pretty cool but if you
haven't it's a good Christmas horror
movie and like I said make maybe make
you feel better about your uh terrible
family so make you make you feel like
not so bad because this family is just
all kind of crazy horrible [__] happens
and they just say all kinds of terrible
things so yeah um again thanks for
coming by uh we will be back tomorrow
night talking both of us talking about a
movie we're doing kind of a weird one
tomorrow night this one was actually
Tom's recommendation I had never seen it
it came out in the '90s um even though
it's like right up my alley I don't know
how I missed it but he actually saw it a
long time ago it was one of his
ex-wife's favorite movies and he
couldn't believe that I had never seen
it he's like cuz this is so you I can't
believe that you have never seen it so
we watched it the other night and it's
not the type of movie we would usually
do do I guess um and it's not usually
the type of movie that Tom would like
but he really digs it and it's called
Orlando and it's from 1993 1994
something like that Tilla swient and is
in it and it's based on a Virginia wolf
novel so it's pretty it's weird it's
like I really liked it but um yeah we'll
we're going to talk about that tomorrow
night so that should be like a really
good discussion cuz Tom really likes
that movie and we like had this big long
discussion about it like afterward but
yeah that's what we're going to talk
about tomorrow night and then on
Wednesday night our show is going to be
about uh the mythology of dragons that
was what won in the poll this week so
we're excited about that that should be
pretty fun so uh so yeah we'll see you
guys again uh tomorrow night bye